i am not a liar you have a lot of
nerve don't talk to me like that
seriously or what
or nothing right exactly
the edges on those diamonds are sharper
than ever
as the season 11 trailer for the real
housewives of beverly hills
puts the ladies and their drama front
and center
i did not see it ending this way i was
going to hold that man's hand till he
died the trailer focuses heavily on
erica jane and her divorce from
estranged husband
tom girardi amid their ongoing legal
troubles
erica filed for divorce in november
after 21 years of marriage
and a month later the couple was accused
of embezzlement
in a lawsuit at the time et learned
they're also being accused of faking
their split
as a means of facilitating the alleged
embezzlement
with any of the lawsuits like did you
have a heads up
is that why you got divorced no i did
not
did you know an ambassador no one knows
the answer
but him fellow housewife garcelle bouvet
opened up about erica's struggles and if
we'd see them play out in front of the
cameras
when she spoke with e.t in march does
she talk about
the divorce does she talk about all the
lawsuits that's going does she go there
or is she like not saying anything she
goes there i'm very proud of her she
goes there when i think she didn't have
to but she did
that surprises me meanwhile erica isn't
the only housewife
bringing the drama i'm going with my
friend
that's lisa rinna facetiming with her 19
year old daughter amelia
hamlin who's been dating 37 year old
scott disick since late 2020
and kyle richards has got something to
say about their 18-year age gap
he's too damn old he's old and you've
got three kids
fans will also officially meet the
newest faces in the 90210
like crystal minkoff who's the wife of
director rob minkoff who directed the
oscar-nominated animated feature the
lion king
and though crystal is new it seems like
she can certainly hold her own
as she does during this tense moment
with now full-time cast member sutton
strack
you're an inappropriate awkward person
because you're jealous
whoa period you crystal i'm
jealous of what your ugly leather pants
paris hilton's mom kathy hilton also
makes her debut on the long-running
series
here look how beautiful that's the way
we like it
kathy joins her sister and original
beverly hills housewife
kyle richards but noticeably absent
their other sister
kim richards who left the show in 2017.
i texted her and i didn't hear back kim
changed her number
she did as for garcelle who joined the
show in 2019
she tells et that when it comes to
season 11
you better buckle your seatbelt how you
feeling any
wounds any flesh wounds like how are you
i'm going to therapy
let me tell you now um actually this
season was really interesting mean
uh we have two new we have two new
friends we have a house a new housewife
and we have a new friend kathy hilton
and uh it was really interesting to have
new dynamics and not be the new girl
but at the same time there's a lot going
on obviously with you know
erica and just a lot of things going on
did they come for you
at times yeah at times they were you
know but that's what the show's about
if it's a kumbaya moment nobody wants to
watch that so you kind of want to see a
little bit of drama
and there definitely is not